[Music]  getting dumped is hard but now there's  an easier way to get over your ex  introducing his loss his loss is a  smartphone app that monitors your  ex-boyfriends social media postings and  sends you the information that matters  most details about his hair loss you'll  get daily updates about his rapidly  receding hairline 2news centimeters of  scalp and detailed analytics about his  future prospects plus you'll be able to  choose in-app purchases such as aerial  drones surveillance and text alerts  every time he blows money on expensive  baldness treatments sure it might make  you a terrible person but at least  you've still got your hair and from the  makers of his loss it's her game we're  looking up way up  [Music]  [Applause]  you